hello everyone
and welcome to another episode of
connecting the dots this is going to be
our last episode for the year so
thank you for showing up and hanging out
with us today on the show we have
jordan jackson jordan thank you so much
for taking the time to hang out with us
today
of course man i love talking to everyone
about the journey just because i know
what it was like for me so
i just love to just spread like what i
went through to know like there's a
light at the end of the tunnel so
absolutely yeah and you know it's been
it has been a long year
it's uh it's been tough for i know
people even even before the pandemic
started it was
it was getting tough to get into tech
and um and so
you know i'm really excited to talk to
you about your story and and
how you've done it um so for those who
aren't familiar do you want to let us
know
what are what are you doing now for work
currently i'm at twitter as a software
engineer my working
rehabilitation and remediation team cool
so what our team does is
for the bad actors on twitter we're
responsible for
educating and remediating those users to
kind of educate them on
how they're using the platform
incorrectly or how they're
not uh doing what the terms of service
uh what they're what they agreed to when
they signed up so
we're kind of in charge for that it's
pretty it's a pretty broad like problem
space
so uh we could be working on stuff that
suspends people
uh so it's like the i guess the
remediation part and then
uh we're working on like the remediation
part later where
we can be educating users uh so that
they could hopefully not do the same
things in the future
yeah that's and that's a that's a
stressful space to be in like
is is that like when you're working in
that kind of in that kind of space
do you feel like
i get i how do how does it feel to work
in that space where it's kind of you
you're almost kind of thrown into it
into a spot where you're working with
the the the worst of the bunch right
that's the perfect way to describe it so
when i first came to twitter which i'm
sure we'll get to
i was an intern and then uh i interned
on two teams so the first team was more
like a library team
and the second team was the team that
i'm currently on and it was just kind of
funny to be like an intern and coming to
twitter because like you said you're
working on
the nastiest content so you'll be like
testing and uh you'll be seeing like the
actual reports coming in traffic and uh
yeah you see some stuff that you
probably wouldn't want to see so may
have to take like a
a second or two to stop looking at it
but yes you do see that
uh but it it's kind of bad to see the
stuff that people post but i mean
then again i always think like it's the
internet so you're going to see some
crazy stuff
but at the same time i do really love it
because i know it is probably one of
like the
most impactful teams to be on at twitter
which is making it like a safer
place so i mean so like taking it like
hand in hand i actually love being on my
team
yeah yeah i mean and that like that's
such a cool thing too because it's the
important work right like it's
it's not necessarily the the most fun
job if you were to list out all the
things you want to do every day
like dealing with people who are kind of
out for out to
wreak a little havoc is maybe not what
i'd put at the top of my list
but helping make that safer
helping make helping make that platform
more
you know friendly and accessible to
people so that they feel safe on it
that's that means a lot and i i think
so thank you for does uh i just say like
when i first got like into coding and
like software
everyone would always ask like what do
you want to work on
or something like that like yeah what
are you building
uh or even if you're going to companies
like what team do you want to be honest
like when you first get started
i like had no clue of any of that so
i got really lucky with getting on a
team this in a problem space that i
really enjoy being here
so yeah you seem like the job
description you probably like no way i
don't want to deal with like
all this hateful stuff all day but uh
but yeah working on making it a safer
space for people is definitely
like i felt a lot of pride absolutely
and you should that's
that's a really i love that um well cool
so
so i would love to talk a little bit
about um
how you got to twitter you you mentioned
a little bit you did some internships
but i want to go even before that so
what were you doing before
you were in tech before i'm using tech
so i guess that would be when i joined
the air force when i was
i believe 19 and i got sent to
california
uh funny story about that is from i'm
from uh detroit michigan so
okay from the other side of the country
so uh when you go to like basic training
uh usually everyone has like this what
they call their dream sheet where they
want to go somewhere in the world like i
don't know italy like germany
and uh by the time i went to basic
training i was just like i just want to
go back home
you know i'm like i'm still like a
teenager i'm just like i want to go back
home so
i put like all east coast bases on my
dream sheet
and then i had california and i was just
like oh that'd be cool to go to
california
and i totally didn't think i was going
to get it and i ended up getting sent to
california
so fast forward um i'm in california i
always knew i wanted to like
create like a company one day mostly it
was just like designing like products
and like a sketch pad but
i never knew that i would want to start
like a tech company or software company
so
that came as i was at my first base and
uh
at that time i was like 20 i just used
to read like a lot of startup books and
vlogs like you know like the lean
startup
and zero to one just reading everything
and pretty much i got to a point where
i had ideas i had all the startup
knowledge teaching myself about equity
and venture capital
but i didn't have anyone to build it and
so you started looking for like
resources who's going to build my idea
and you see like oh this
could be like 50 000 to make it happen
uh
they have to pay them like 60 an hour
and i'm like
i'm like 21. it was like i can't afford
anything on that so
uh yeah i ended up reaching out to a few
people just just kind of like
running around just shooting my shot
like trying to see who would work with
me
but uh pretty much that ended up uh
getting me to the point where i got
really frustrated with finding someone
to build something for me so
uh that was the day i just kind of like
got mad and i was just like you know
what if i can't find like a technical
co-founder
i'm gonna be my own technical co-founder
and so that was the thought process
that uh how i ended up learning how to
code
uh which i started doing i believe about
three times um it was like the first
couple times just like yeah
maybe this is not for me yeah i got to
the point where i was just like
i should learn how to code you learn how
to code you don't need a technical
co-founder
you can build whatever you want you
don't have to pay anyone so that was
step one to me learn how to code uh then
the second step is uh i wasn't too fond
of my job in the military i was one of
the guys uh where you just sign up and
like i want to leave as soon as possible
[Laughter]
and they uh they just kind of give you a
job so you don't really have like
any kind of say so in it so you just get
stuck
so one thing about the job was that we
would have downtime so i was like
the airport manager at the base okay so
uh if there weren't any planes flying it
would be
super quiet so i got a lot of coding now
while
there weren't any flights but for me not
liking that job
uh that's how i really got serious about
coding because i felt like it
it just checked out so many boxes for me
because
uh being in the military since pretty
much since high school
uh it was like the only thing i knew
like a lot of people in the military are
like oh you know like we don't really
want to
get out because it's really secure so
yeah yeah it's kind of like it's just
easy to just sign up and just
keep going um but i knew i didn't want
to stay in i know i wanted to build my
own products and know when to start my
own tech company one day so
uh so coding checked off all of those
boxes yeah
uh i also had a daughter uh like maybe
i think it was like two years before i
got out so
it was just like okay i need to be my
daughter i need to start a company one
day
i need to make money to take care of my
family uh pretty much like all of these
boxes and then i was just like man cody
kind of like
like checks off all of this yeah that
was the point where i got like
really serious and so uh when i say
serious i mean like
no video games uh because like i said
i've been uh
like before we started the call i was
telling jason i've been playing
cyberpunk and it is not crashing to me
but
i used to play video games but at that
point i was just like i can't afford to
do that i need the code so
uh i discovered free code count i'm not
i don't even remember how i discovered
it
but i mean i just love how it's just
like laid out like okay
like you start here from knowing
absolutely nothing and then at the end
it's like okay here's this calculator i
built with like four different
technologies
so that was what i really that's what
really stuck me on free code cam
and yeah i just was kind of relentless
uh
from that point and i just if i had free
time at work or at home
i was coding so um that that is like
from like a to to be how i got
into like coding like from the start
yeah
i started it my daughter's name a lot of
movies but so
that's that's actually kind of a really
interesting thing like something that
that i found
fascinating about that is you said that
you had downtime at work
right and um this is interesting because
i
i ended up doing the same thing and i
hadn't really thought too much about it
but
i worked at a hotel as a night audit
clerk for
for a long time and that meant that my
job was like
if nobody came to the desk which most
nights nobody would i had like 45
minutes of work to run an audit
at 3am and otherwise i just did whatever
i wanted so i got to do all of this
coding work
as like on the clock for my other job
and you got to do the same thing as a as
an airport manager
how how much do you think that like
factored in to your ability to stick
with it
uh so i feel like it was kind of it was
too low so
uh so one we were on twelves for a good
amount of the time so
okay we were there a lot so always tell
people when you're on like 12-hour
shifts it would have like maybe three to
four of them
but it would be like you work your 12
hours you get home you have enough time
to get ready for bed
and wake up and go back so so it was
kind of like sometimes
it felt like that was the only time i
did have but i feel like it factored in
a lot
and uh from that like you said with my
job it's like once the pilots would
finish flying for the night
uh i might have like a five hour gap
so i mean it's like a lot of people
watch youtube don't you do a crossword
puzzle or sudoku but
i was like man this is like gold uh you
can get paid yeah
learn a different job and then also like
i said i really really didn't like my
job so
it was like what better thing to do at a
job you don't like than to
study for a better job yeah so that was
probably
not only is that when i got the most
time to code uh it was probably when i
did my best coding because i was just
like i gotta get out of here i gotta get
out of here so
uh just because i know it's not where i
wanted to be so i said
it was like two parts to it so i feel
like it was
a huge factor uh and that's also what i
tell a lot of people that i try to get
into it
um i always like to tell people that i
feel like anyone could code but
you need like a motivator so that was my
i was at work
which i knew i didn't like being at work
uh it was very motivating for me to
like just go hard the whole time i was
there it's like i'm not doing anything
i need to be working so yeah
yeah man that that is that that hits
close to home for me because i i felt
the same way you know i had
jobs that i didn't like and i never
found something that felt right and my
my motivator was always to
get something that i liked and so like
learning the code was
i saw that as a path out so that that's
really cool and and you know this
this clearly worked for you right you're
you're at twitter now so how did you go
from
you know you were you were working you
were learning code at your other job
that you wanted to get out of
and you've you've since obviously you're
no longer in the military you're now
working at twitter how did that journey
happen like where how did you kind of
get from from
learning to having the job
so i always say it's like a being at the
right place at the right time um
one of the things when i first got
started and i uh i acquired my internet
and twitter
i almost didn't like to tell the story
because i felt like it was it just kind
of like seemed like a movie moment
and i was just like i mean of course i
mean i never thought it would happen to
me and
someone else would have told me i would
have been like oh yeah that's never
gonna happen to me but
i did but so from those long nights
coding
and in like my job on the military base
uh there will be pilots that will come
in all the time and of course we're
we're at a travis surfers base so this
is probably like i believe the biggest
air force base
uh in uh like silicon valley area
so i feel like a lot of the pilots they
like new
people like in those circles um so
one night i would be coding and i would
just come in and
talk to the pilots and uh one thing i
kind of noticed early on is the whole
it's not what you know is who you know
thing so i noticed that networking was
like very important
so i would just talk to everyone so
before i was coding i would talk to
people about like oh i want to have a
business one day
uh whether or not it turned into
something fruitful i would just talk
about it just because it was always on
my mind
uh so one of the pilots uh he came in
one night and we were just talking about
code and stuff and we mentioned
something about
uh like the twitter blackburners or
something and that's like the employee
research group for uh for black people
and uh he's just said like he knew one
of them i was just like oh what are the
chances of that
so he said he knew someone there was a
blackbird and i was just like oh you
know can you
introduce me to this person so you know
just
totally just uh making conversation and
he was like sure so
he ended up introducing me to this
person
and uh she was awesome we ended up like
just making like this
this bond brother sister bond over like
i would say the course of maybe like
12 to 18 months i would say okay this
whole time i'm always talking to her
just letting her know how my progress is
going
uh telling her she has to save me from
this job
[Laughter]
stuff like that um and just kind of just
telling her like my goals and
okay i learned how to do this and uh
this whole time she's like
we never had like a like a formal like
plan
um it was more of just she was just
telling me about the opportunities that
were out there
uh so i just kept in contact with her
and so i just kept coding
and coding and then eventually we get to
the point where i'm like on the last
couple months of like my my listening
and uh like you have to go to this class
where they
they try to get you ready to get a job
as a civilian and
i'm just like man i don't want a regular
job you know like i want to be an
engineer
and so eventually she just approached me
and she was just like
uh okay i have this plan um if you can
pass an interview i can get you an
internship at twitter
and so uh i'm like like what like i'm
like this is crazy so
uh like first uh twitter doesn't have
like a program like this
now we do which is actually pretty funny
now we do actually have a
apprenticeship program where if you're a
person you come from like a
non-traditional background you can come
into twitter as an apprentice
and uh actually become a full-time
software engineer but
at this time it was just like you had to
go to college um
yeah it was really like a like uh this
is for you
and it's like you just passed the
interview and i was just like i have to
pass the interview so
from that point forward i mean i was
already pretty focused
so i ended up having some mentors just
teach me
uh all of the sorts that i'm pretty sure
we got like the
merge swords and bubble swords and every
uh i think i did interview cake
oh yeah yeah i was doing like everything
i could a hacker rank i was doing as
many hacker ranks as i could
um like because i just i really really
wanted it was just like man this is my
shot
i like if i fumble this this is like
going to be the worst
fumble in history or at least for my
life yeah well and so
there's actually a question from the
chat oliver is asking um
so you tackled the coding interviews by
doing hacker rank interview cake things
like that
how was the the coding interview at
twitter
uh it was actually easier than i thought
um i it was so it was for intern of
course it was an intern
so i mean i guess that's where like i
said it's for
students that just completed their
bachelor's so i'm not sure like how that
ranks uh for
like a like another junior engineer but
for me i feel like it was pretty it was
pretty simple
uh they did hit me with a question the
interview was pretty funny because
like i said i feel like i prepared a lot
but um with these engineering interviews
i feel like i don't really have a good
analogy off the top of my head but
i feel like you could prepare for like
99 of the problems but somebody hit you
with that one
question you like never just
you never got that far to study that it
just it could be
like detrimental so i felt like i did
really good with my interview
one of the questions i remember
uh was like if you have like a stack
you're putting numbers on the stack
how do you access the highest number in
the stack in constant time
um so that was one of the questions i
had uh so i i definitely
like had something like that before so i
was able to solve that
and then uh the other question that i
got that i'll never forget because
i knew i couldn't solve this problem
beforehand and like i said it was just
like uh
please not this question
so uh it was the one it's like uh if you
have like a a
n by n matrix or something okay or by m
matrix
uh like how do you get from like the top
left corner to the bottom right corner
and i think it also includes like the
just some spaces you can't go
oh okay like yeah i just like admit it
i'm terrible with
matrices like when it comes to code like
i do not like
trying to traverse like the matrix like
with the code um so
that was a question i got and uh i did
good on all the other questions but when
i got that question
it like it felt like someone pulled out
like a steak and i was just like man
this is it
but so so when you got that question you
just told them you know like this is
the you just kind of you're like look
this i this isn't for me
yes so yeah they definitely so like i
said it was a unique situation so they
were like okay we're not
uh i mean everyone at twitter they were
kind of like it was a new process
because like oh we never interviewed
someone right
but you know you didn't go to college
for computer science so it's like we
don't know what you learned
um so she just kind of uh she was nice
enough to like kind of gauge
like where i was at so she asked me that
question and i was just like i think i
pretty much just tell them i was like
uh i think i tried person i'm just like
yeah i can solve this and
uh she ended up making like a taking me
like to a simpler version of the problem
that i was able to say
oh nice i started building my way up to
uh like almost solving the the one that
i couldn't solve in the first place
that's cool so yeah so it's like i mean
um that's one thing that it's not all
about solving a problem uh
it's about like kind of like seeing how
you could collaborate and work through
learning the problem so so yeah we had
really great communication
and i was just like yeah i guess all
that is okay let's see what you can
solve and
work up to that so you know overall it
was a good result but
still stake to the heart you bring up a
really good point though which is
like i actually think that at least for
me
one of the things that i'm looking for
when i'm interviewing is
someone's self-awareness and their
willingness to ask for help and so if
if i was interviewing someone and i
asked them a question they didn't know
the answer to
if they were to kind of close down and
get frustrated and
and try to solve and not ask for help to
me that's kind of a
that's a sign that it's not going to
work out right i'm looking
i'm looking for what you did i'm looking
for someone to say
you know i haven't done this before i
i'm not sure if i was going to start i'd
start like this but i don't really know
where to go from there
and then you know what you have the
conversation how do you think about code
how do you
how are you going to approach solving
this problem because
in a real job you're not going to be
solving it like traverse an n by n
matrix
yeah right never seen a matrix sin
yeah exactly right so i'm not really
interested in whether or not you
memorized how to traverse a matrix i'm
i'm interested in how you would approach
solving that problem
um because like i don't think i could
solve that problem like
i don't work with matrices ever
it's a couple problems like that where
it's like i don't ever i don't
ever want to leave twitter because i'm
just like if i get one of these problems
i'm just like
i'm going back to my office uh the other
one is like i don't know it's like find
the
the large the largest set of increasing
numbers in like a
a set of numbers and it's just like yeah
i couldn't i think i've seen a solution
to that one
and i've watched like three videos on it
and i'm like i don't get how
laughs like a dark magic at this point
i'm just like uh yeah i'ma just keep my
job
and i'm not gonna fool around with these
the algorithm problems definitely get me
i uh yeah and i like i feel
for people who are are are trying to get
through that because i i feel like those
algorithm problems are
are one of those things it's like taking
a test in in school it's you're you're
cramming for
test taking not really for the job um
so actually that's there's a question
there which is uh
a couple people asked adarsh asked uh
how are you staying motivated especially
when it's something
kind of frustrating so when you were
first learning and then uh probably
asked like
when you're moving on to the next topic
uh they they forget the one that they
learned before so
how when you're learning how do you go
about like keeping your motivation up
and making sure you retain the stuff
that you're learning
making sure i retain uh so is this like
in reference to interviewing or like
i think i'm always just kind of curious
about like
learning processes in general so when
you when you're going to learn anything
whether it's studying for an interview
or you just
you've got a new problem you want to
tackle how would you break down you know
not getting frustrated uh and staying
motivated to learn it
and also making sure that as you're
learning it you're retaining
the the new information okay so first i
would tackle like the the retention part
uh so i feel like that's just the easier
part for me so i definitely
would say that uh when it comes to like
learning how to code and learning like
the different subjects
i don't think i worry about retention at
all just because i feel like
oh if you do it enough it's gonna like
stick and
i always like to tell people when they
first start learning you don't have to
remember
everything off the top of your head like
we have so many resources
available when you're doing your job day
to day so i like to tell people like
that like i
stay on google a lot at work so uh so
when it comes to retention
i don't really feel like you have to
retain every bit of knowledge you have
uh or every knowledge that you're
reading about on a particular topic
uh i would say you just need to keep a
reference to it so it's not like a
being an engineer is not like a closed
book test at all
like i feel like you you can ask anyone
you guys google
you could probably ask jason if he has
time you guys need yeah
yeah so it's not like a closed book
texas if you
if you don't uh remember something if
you could remember
like i don't know like i remember i was
teaching my auntie how to code
and i forgot how to do a closing tag in
html and like i'm saying this is
probably like a month or two ago
in html and i'm just like mass is
embarrassing
i'm just like i have to google it like
to see like how do you close the tag
html so
that is something i don't feel like i
would ever forget but unless you're like
working with it every day
i don't like you're gonna just be like
super fluent in it and remember it off
the top of your head
but i know how to google how do you
close the tag in html
and i'm like oh i know how to do it now
you know i i honestly i feel like that
is the most valuable skill that we learn
is like
i don't think that a senior developer
staff developer
is necessarily a better developer than
anyone else
i think they've just learned more of the
vocabulary more of the context
so they know what to google like if you
know if i ask
um what i've noticed a lot is that when
i'm
talking to someone who's just learning
they're like i don't know how to solve
this and i'm looking at the problem
they're solving i'm saying okay well
what would you search and they're like i
don't know i don't know what this is
called
and so the the learning isn't
necessarily
i don't know how to solve this problem
it's i don't even know what to
call this problem i don't know where to
start looking for a solution
and so the more we learn the more we
build that vocabulary and that
that web where we can say i've seen a
problem kind of like this
i think this is called matrix traversal
or or whatever right and then we know
what to google to go figure out how to
solve that problem
um i would definitely agree with that
just like
like what problem you're solving but i
don't think like trying to retain
everything like software is just
it's just it's just too vast and i mean
yeah i mean it's not also
i mean in addition to it being gas it's
evolving so it's like
there's new stuff coming out and then
the stuff you're already working with is
still like evolving so it's just
memorized everything so it's just good
to kind of just keep like a mental map
of like
okay like i know the gist of it to where
i can google for help
but uh something that surprised me too
when i first got to twitter
uh of course this is my first
engineering job ever so i'm thinking
like okay
like i'm just someone to learn how to
code on free code camp and i'm here with
everyone that went to like berkeley and
mit and i was just like oh god
uh thinking everyone would know
everything off the top of their head but
uh but it was really refreshing to see
like the uh the more senior engineers
like and they have like the same
questions i do meetings or
uh you ask them for help and like
they'll google stuff that you're like
wow i don't think he would know that off
the top of his head or
um like i'm surprised they didn't know
that uh
i mean so it's not like a like a slight
to them it's just like it's competent to
know like oh this is
what being an engineer is like it's not
like you have to know everything
it's not like jeopardy where it's just
like hey you can't act
so that is definitely like uh comforting
to me to see
uh for sure on like acts and stuff like
that and then what was the second part
of the question
the second part of the question was
about staying motivated because a lot of
times especially when we're learning
things like coding it's it's abstract it
can feel like it's a whole lot and we're
never going to learn it all which
as you've just stated we never will
we're never going to learn at all
so how do you how do you keep from
getting discouraged and keep your
motivation up when you're when you're
trying to tackle something that's
challenging
uh so i would i feel like i'm i'm
probably gonna be like uh
i don't want people to be like me when i
was learning so when i was learning like
i had a pretty strong motivator which
was the military and i didn't
like my situation so that was all the
motivation i needed i was like hey you
don't do this
you're going to be stuck here so that
was like that was my motivation so
uh so i feel like that's kind of it's
not like not that it doesn't apply to
everyone right so it's like i feel like
everyone has to find like a reason that
they're coding because
like i said i feel like anyone can do it
but if you don't have like to keep
motivated
i don't feel like uh it's gonna be a lot
harder
uh something that i would do differently
when i was learning is
i took this kind of like siloed approach
where i would just
uh learn like i'll take my laptop either
at work or at home and i'll just learn
so
i know free code account has like the
like chats and forums that you can go
and ask for help
and i was pretty stubborn about it i was
just like look if i can't learn this by
myself i don't want to learn it
and i would spend like hours on a
problem like
but as long as i could complete it by
myself i would uh i would spend the time
so i would say definitely learning with
others
like because i mean i feel like your
team you can like keep each other
accountable
uh kind of keep the momentum going um so
i definitely wouldn't
suggest learning alone unless you have
like a very
extreme motivator like i did um and then
uh so that was my motivator while i was
like in the military but
uh now that i'm uh like i'm actually
engineering on that twitter now
i would say what motivates me is uh just
trying to figure out how to be like a
better engineer
um it wasn't like always the best when i
first transitioned
it was pretty tough going from like the
military background to tech
um for a lot of reasons mostly like
being
in the military and being at a tech
company or like polar opposites
uh so you know i couldn't even have a
beard when i was in the military so you
know i'm like i get to have a beard
i get to say hey to the ceo at lunch you
know
so it was it was pretty tough at first
but
i find just trying to figure it out and
be like a
better engineer is a pretty good
motivator for me yeah
just because i still feel like sometimes
some days i still feel like a puppy uh
in the engineering world so
so that's a pretty big motivator for me
yeah well and it's cool too like i
i think there's a threshold that gets
crossed like i've
i've uh i've seen this in a lot of folks
where when they're first starting to
learn to code it feels
like it feels like going to math class
or it feels like going to
you know to an english class where
you're breaking down grammar you're
you're trying to memorize algorithms
you're trying to do stuff that
you're like i don't get how any of this
is going to work and then there's a
threshold you cross where it starts to
make sense
and you go from having to think really
really hard about how anything works
to where you can kind of just you can
just write a little bit of code and you
can start to build things
and when you move from that like i have
to struggle to remember how the syntax
works
to i know the syntax now i can just kind
of do that by feel
and and i can just build the thing that
i want to build
that's where i've started to see a lot
of you know there's momentum and there's
motivation
because now you're not it's not
frustrating or as frustrating you're
you're now able to like
create something and as soon as you get
to that point where you can create
it's like oh now what else could i
create what else could i make
and and you it creates like a positive
feedback loop where you
you get to see yourself succeed and each
one of those successes gives you more
motivation to try the next thing
um and i i love you know it's but it's
also hard because you got to push that
boulder up that hill to get the momentum
like you've got to cross that threshold
yeah so i try to trust me i try to get
almost everyone i know to code
yeah my wife she's been batting me away
for years at this point
but uh i always tell people whenever you
get started you just have to trust the
process
uh if you get started on free code count
it's going to look like gibberish
uh of course but i would say when i
started when i got serious on pre-code
count i would say
it was maybe it could have been more
than like a few weeks to where
i would like stand back from the screen
i'd be like whoa like i'm actually
writing this
like this is pretty crazy um so there's
definitely like a point you'll get to
where
you can see the growth like you'll see
yourself writing stuff and you'll be
like
uh two weeks ago this would have this
would have never made any sense this was
like like you wouldn't even know it
would look like alien uh code or
something like that but
uh so i definitely like uh agree uh and
then also i like to compare
uh coding to english it's like i feel
like when people say like i can't learn
how to code it's too hard
i was like what if you would have said
like oh i can't learn english it's too
hard like you a baby like you just
i'm not gonna try uh it sounds like
gibberish i'm never gonna learn how to
put like the correct grammar and
punctuation
i'm just going to talk about the baby
forever um so uh so
that's what uh that's the analogy i use
um when my family or friends tell me
coding is too hard i'm just like
you speak english right uh i mean
apparently i've heard english as one of
the harder languages to learn so it is
yeah
so it's like you can learn english you
learn how to code i mean it's not
uh it's not that much different you just
have to trust yourself that you're gonna
by immersion eventually you're gonna
start coding so
absolutely so like you said when you
start pushing the motor
you just have to realize i mean this is
kind of like a boater that gets smaller
as you push it so
yep that's just something to keep in
mind when you uh first get started
yeah yeah that's such a that's such a
cool thing um so something i'd love to
talk
a little bit more about is you you
mentioned that like your path
into your internship opportunity was
was not like an overnight thing this was
something that you built over
more than a year um and i want to talk a
little bit about that because i think
that people
undervalue this part of getting a job
and and you already said this but it's
it's not what you know it's who you know
um and so uh to just recap a little bit
you you were working in the airport
through a pilot
you got connected to somebody who was a
part of the blackbirds organization at
twitter and you could have stopped there
you could have said that's so cool that
you know somebody who's a blackbird at
twitter and then
never said anything right but you asked
you were like hey i can i
get connected and then after you got
connected
you kept in touch you updated on
progress and you you
kept doing the work and showing your
work and eventually that led
to her doing some work to get you the
interview right and so
that i think is such a fascinating like
it would be so easy to say oh i know a
blackbird of twitter
and then you just kind of like well
right now that's somebody i know on
on the internet and like i like their
posts sometimes
or you can put that work in you can
build that network
um how have you found networking
like obviously in this case it played a
huge role but like have you seen it play
in other aspects of your life or in
other aspects of your career
where it's been beneficial like that uh
yes definitely not
uh so much like definitely not like
getting into twitter but
there are a few instances i have uh so
for example
i was on twitter uh i don't even i don't
think i even knew how to code at this
point right even begun to go but
uh it was someone i think he is the i
think he may be the cto of coinbase
right now
uh balaji but he uh he was like he came
out with this like
bitcoin computer back then uh and
i just remember he came out with it and
i forgot how old i was but it was like
400 dollars
and i was just like man you know i can't
afford that so
i ended up just like i dm'd him or i
tweeted at him i was just like oh you
know like i actually like a
product tester or something and he's
like oh um send me an email or something
and he ended up sending me one for free
um with some feedback
and uh so at the time i mean uh coming
from
like never having anything like that
happen i'm just like
wow i've got this free it was like a
raspberry pi but they were selling them
for like 400 because they had bitcoin
mining chips in them oh okay yeah uh
yeah and he just gave me one for free so
that was pretty powerful to me just
be like hey just tweeting i can get like
free stuff
that was like my first taste of like oh
wow you just like talk to the right
person
uh they could make things happen for you
another thing is i had reached out to
someone
and they got me like a it wasn't like an
internship it was more like a
it was a startup and uh they were i
forgot the name of it but
uh they were doing like um problem
solving like they would take problems
from like companies and come up with
like solutions and
uh i ended up like doing like a i
wouldn't sell like an internship but i
was like building like a
dashboard for them okay it was probably
like the first
the first full stacked app i ever built
and they were paying me like uh
like 500 bucks like a month or something
like that but it was kind of crazy
because i was just like what
um it was like i guess you can say that
was the first time i got paid for
coding but uh but again that was like a
connection i made on twitter where i was
just
reaching out to people like hey you know
like this is what i'm trying to do this
is what i'm interested in
uh do you know anybody that can help so
it's just like you never know
like who you're talking to or uh like
what they know who they know
what they can what they have access to
um and that works both ways because i
met some
people that were pretty uh like
i call them lumberjacks because i feel
like they chop your dreams down but
i met a few lumberjacks you know so
lumberjacks
they can be people that are in great
positions too but
they may not just see things like you
see them so you have to stay away from
them
yeah but yeah so i just found just
talking to people
and then like i said i mean don't force
it but i feel like it just actually
comes out like if you're coding all the
time
or you're trying to make a company i
feel like it's on your mind so you start
talking to anybody like
in a coffee shop or um online like
you're just gonna
naturally just like hey this is kind of
what i'm into and what i'm working on
um so so those are two times where i got
like a huge example of like hey you talk
to people
tell them what you're interested in and
like hey i mean people
i mean a lot of people say this people
want to see you succeed like i mean it's
like
all they have to do is make like an
intro and you know like
i can have like what i consider like i
feel like i'm living in alternate
reality
i say that a lot like uh not on twitter
i feel like i'm
like i just i should still be in the
military right now but it's like i
put the work in and met some cool people
and now i'm with
a better version of my life so uh so so
if you can live a better version of your
life and also
have to do is uh make an intro people
will do that i feel like
like a lot of people will do that so
speaking as as someone who's had the
opportunity to make a couple of those
intros
nothing feels better than being the
person who can help
a you know if i have a friend who's
looking to hire and i have someone who's
looking for a job
and i can put them together and like
everybody ends up happy
i feel amazing like nothing feels better
than being able to help
two people solve a problem and you know
to so
when when we're talking about like
make yourself available to people show
people what you're doing that's not
that's not selfish you are you are being
just as good a member of the community
by letting people know that you
are looking for work what kind of work
you're looking for what your strengths
are
like if i see that and i see that you're
looking i have a bunch of friends who
work in tech
who are always like hey do you know a
good like distributed systems engineer
hey do you know a good like
senior node engineer if i can see people
in my network who are doing that work
and looking i am 100
going to connect them every time but if
i don't know what you're working on i
don't know what you're interested in i'm
not just going to like
haphazardly recommend you for a job so
it you're you're doing everyone a favor
when you do that
like i yeah i cannot stress that enough
like how helpful it is to me yeah i have
a
funny fact i like to say that uh i mean
it's it sounds so
insane when i say it out loud but uh
when i got out the military
i only put in one job application oh man
that is wild
and that was the twitter so uh yeah i
had a
uh my daughter was one at the time and
a lot of people like to go like to this
thing called tax where like i said they
teach you how to
get a job when you get out and help make
your resume and um
it's like i put in one application uh
and i'm just still like blown away like
man i was really confident but like i
said i was really going hard studying
and everything for my uh
for my interview so so yes i was like uh
i mean
i was just telling myself like like
failure is just not an option here
i mean i like that though like i think
there's something to be said for
for going all in on a plan um i that was
that was sort of a thing that i did as
well i i got exactly enough freelance
work that i wouldn't
like get kicked out of my house like i
had enough to clear rent and i was like
whatever i'll eat ramen i'm going all in
on being a software engineer
and i quit my day job and i like
immediately that
that confidence that i felt when i quit
like
i had a rough couple of months where i
did i cleared rent and that was just
about it i ate a lot of like cup noodles
but
man i i was i was an engineer like it
felt
real and that let me land more clients
that let me like go
all in on this job and that's led to me
being where i am now and so i love
i love when somebody bets on themselves
like it's it's one of my favorite things
to see put all the eggs in one basket so
that was but yeah like i said i built
that relationship
for 18 months and then when it came to
the interview like i was
i think i was doing like maybe every
other day like
uh video calls like with uh here who's
helping me
uh she's helping me learn like
algorithms and the sorts and stuff
oh so you had like an interview coach
yeah so i didn't have any
coaches that's good good i guess i left
a part of my story out uh
so when when the pilot made the intro
to the uh lady at twitter i ended up
going there for the first time
and i just went to the hq and just met
her um
and that was uh i met like a few
engineers i was when i met like the
first
few engineers i've ever met and um like
a couple of those people i just kept in
contact with them so
uh like yeah one of them were they were
my interview coach
someone twitter was my interview coach
that's really nice but yeah so i would
go up there almost every chance i can
get
um i think i live where i lived it was
maybe like an hour and a half from the
uh
sf hq um so it was kind of a hike but
i mean it was so cool like that was one
of the the biggest things that was a big
motivator too
so uh anyone could get i mean when the
world opens
back up you can get like a tour of like
a tech company i feel like that's pretty
motivating too
um run from the military with our
working conditions
uh not saying like they're like the
worst in the world but compared to like
a tech company
yeah look at the twitter hq like they're
getting uh like we were getting like
breakfast
every day much every day it's like four
cafeterias
you got these snack kitchenettes
everywhere you got famous people that'll
visit us
um uh you get to see jack walking around
which
still my mind uh like it was just uh
like a whole
whole different way everyone's wearing
clothes that they want to wear uh
you can have facial hair
it was just like a felt like a different
planet i mean some places it won't be
that extreme
right military tech company is like the
most extreme i think you can get so i
was like blown away like yeah i had like
people are working here
and i'm like on twelves um so
that definitely like just kind of uh
helped my motivation piece
yeah then that's actually kind of
interesting too
because when you when you made that that
tour
um and like you started keeping in
contact with
with engineers that worked at twitter
you had the interview coach
did you feel like like at that moment
you kind of
started to believe it was possible for
you
uh might be like possible to work at
twitter well just like possible to
have that career to be an engineer to do
the things that you wanted to do
um that's a good question i don't i mean
it kind of sounds like did i feel like i
was ready uh
well i i actually mean it in a different
way so
so there's um the the way that i mean it
is like i i feel like
we have a tendency to sort of put
ourselves into
into whichever box we surround ourselves
with right so like if i'm surrounded by
people who think that
you know like when i was younger a lot
of my friends they all worked in like
warehouses construction things like that
and they all just kind of had assumed
that was as far as they were going to go
and so a lot of my mindset was the same
i was like oh yeah i'll probably just
like you know build houses or something
um and then when i when i started
hanging out with people who thought that
more was possible i was like wait i
could do more i couldn't do more
couldn't i and then i started dreaming
bigger and so i'm kind of wondering like
it sounds like you already had big
dreams like so i'm not saying you know
like
the the getting an intro was there but
like where did you find that threshold
really
was crossed for you where you you
started to really think like you know
what this isn't just a dream i'm gonna
do this
uh so like you said i do think i always
like kind of thought big like i wanted
to
have my own company i didn't think it
would be like software or building uh
like an app or anything like that but
i did get to a point in the military
where like you said it was
exactly like what you just said in the
military uh you retire after doing 20
years of service so
a lot of people i mean that's like oh
you get a retirement check every 20
years so
you'll meet a lot of people did that's
what they want to do they want to do
their 20 years and get out
um and that wasn't my intentions when i
came in like i had a six-year contract
should have been four but i was 19. so
gotta forgive myself
but uh i came in and so now i'm
surrounded by all of these people that
just
they want to do 20 years uh and i'm just
like you know i don't want to do 20
years i mean i didn't know what i wanted
to do
so i think that was probably like a like
a uh like a hindrance for me like oh
i need like a i needed like some
direction nevertheless it's easy to be
caught up in what everyone else wants to
do
so there was a point where i was i
remember saying to myself
i'm going to do 20 years like this is
something like i was like no
way like this is not what i'm doing and
then i remember saying that to myself
and
uh it was actually uh one of uh we had
civilians that we worked with
yeah it's and it was actually one of the
civilians
uh his name was gary and i would always
talk to him because
he wanted to uh buy a porsche 911 when
he retired
okay he was like working on his second
retirement when he retired for the
second time he wanted a fortune 911.
i just always remember that he would uh
talk about like yeah my wife's gonna let
me get it when i'm retiring so
i remember one day i was talking to him
and i told him i was like yeah when i
retired from the military and we get a
porsche like yours
you know just just uh joking around and
stuff
and um like i swear i'll never forget
this he said uh he called me jj because
we called each other by our initials at
work
and he was like jj you don't have to say
goodbye porsche and
i just like no logics and that took me
on like a mind trip i was just like what
does he mean by that
and then it was like at that moment like
the old me
i want to start a company and build
something and
like just not settle for just anything
i just like woke up and like from that
day forward
i just been like hey like i'm gonna be
the ceo like my own company one day
and i don't care what anybody says about
it um so from that day forward like i
was just like
uh and then it also gave me like a
pretty strong shield because
after that day i kind of just realized
like man if you're around like people
just
putting the wrong things into your head
uh you can kind of get like sidetracked
from like your dreams and your goals so
uh from that day i would say yes i feel
like yes i could be an engineer yes i
could be the ceo of my own company
if i want to i could be i could be
anything i want to so
after like shaking that off
uh yes i definitely believed i could
whether i was ready
is a different question but as far as
like the box no boxes i don't do boxes
anymore yeah
i love that though and like who's who's
ever ready like
i honestly if you told me i was going to
interview a twitter tomorrow i don't
know i'd probably bomb it
i definitely bombed it facebook when i
interviewed back a while ago
but you know i think it's one of those
things like i you know i've also
since worked at other startups and i
nailed the technical interviews so a lot
of it is also on like
just taking the chances right like i you
know i worked at ibm
and my technical interview there was
great we like reviewed projects together
and like refactored things and it wasn't
an algorithm interview
facebook i was interviewing for front
end and they were like hey do you want
to write some sql queries and i was like
i don't think i'm interviewing for the
right job
[Laughter]
yeah i write those sometimes at work but
i saw i use google like i just
uh just enough to get like uh like the
data back that uh that's useful for me
but
by no means i'm not pro but but yes
that's how
that is definitely how i feel no no
boxes aren't allowed i can't i can't go
back to that
i love that it's dangerous i mean i
wouldn't be i mean if i would have
stayed in that box
i mean like yes i just i just moved to
michigan um
because of the pandemic we were allowed
to move so i just moved back home
um with my uh to be closer to family and
stuff and i still have my job and i'm
just like
wow i work at twitter i live i'm i'm
back home
you know like i'm seeing my family yeah
and i'm just thinking like this would
have been
non-existent you know if i would have
just stayed in that box like oh
i mean i think i would be i mean i would
have
uh 12 years left before i retired dang
that i wouldn't
have been happy though yeah
so so yeah so that's why i said the
lumberjacks are just you have to
have to stay away from yeah oh man i
love that so much that's
uh and it's such a heartwarming story
like i love i love when you can kind of
draw
like a point like there's there's a
conversation i had that that like
realigned me
and uh and it sounds like talking to to
gary like what a
what a cool moment to be able to just be
like oh yeah
like i almost i almost did a whole
different life
i could have been somebody completely
different dad yeah
i don't know so i actually have i think
it was that same day
it might not have been that same day but
he wrote me a sticky note
um it says your uh your vision
determines your destination
and like yeah i still have that sticky
note in my closet somewhere i'm afraid
but yeah so uh gary he wrote that for me
and
uh thank you like i said it was around
the same time that he told me i wouldn't
have to say for a portion i was just
like
like yeah i just i was just it was crazy
it was just like man he sees like
he obviously sees who i was and like
motivation and the dreams i had when i
first got there and for me it was just
like
always i was in a sunken place pretty
much yeah yeah
i like get out like i'm just like the
real me is down there like just no
so uh yeah so gary he just i can't
remember what they used in the movie but
he just
woke me up and now she's like what oh
yeah so
ever since then it's been like nah uh
i gotta hey even if they 99 percent of
startups well i'm like hey
uh i have to have to play my hand
just to see what it's gonna do so um so
yeah that is
i never forget that moment yeah no no
so i i have a couple a couple more
questions before we wrap up um
so i want to i want to kind of twist
this around we've got a lot of people
watching now who are
just getting into the industry they're
taking free code camp right now
they're they're learning um and so i
want to
just kind of ask you for all the people
who are out there trying to get in
um like one one specific question is
what type of projects did you have in
your portfolio and and
kind of what would you recommend folks
focus on if they're if they're looking
to build their own portfolio
if they're looking to build their own
portfolio so uh when i tell people to
learn now i usually just tell them to go
through
and build like the portfolio stuff
mostly because i feel like that's what
gave me a lot of my confidence at first
like
you feel like i think it was like a
signing game
like a javascript calculator i feel like
all of that is like good stuff
and then um some of the other stuff that
i love i love to do
um and actually i felt like this was
probably the best preparation i had
uh to for being like an engineer at
twitter
and that is following projects on
youtube so
uh it's a guy who watches videos what is
his name
brad his name is brad uh i forgot his
last name
is it traversing media yes yeah yeah
yeah
so i used to watch his videos and he
would uh he would go from like zero to
like
a hundred making like a full full stack
project
and it would be awesome for a portfolio
and not only that but
after i was finished watching brad i
would go in there and like tinker and
like
like my own like app you know so um so i
mean
like you could build it and repurpose it
for something and yeah
probably like the best experience you're
gonna get for
uh like to prepare uh to be an engineer
at like a big company
uh just because something i didn't
realize is that when you're a junior
engineer
you're not going to go into the company
building services from scratch
right oh i feel like that was a big
misconception i had like i'm gonna go in
here
i'm gonna have to start like i'm gonna
have to build like a full stack out but
when you get in you realize that you're
you're only going to be updating
and uh building on existing code like
you're not
starting up as like a service from
scratch like that's mostly like senior
work
senior level work so i mean if you could
come in and do that i mean
yeah you're a rock star but yeah that's
the bar like i have to come in building
like a whole
service from scratch so uh the way i
link those two is
you build like a project from like brad
and then
uh you tinker with it you make
modifications to it you learn how to
code works
and you'll be well prepared to get into
another company
where you're going to get thrown into
like a super random code base
uh you're just going to have to go and
do the exact same thing which is
learning how it works and learning how
to update and extend it
um so i would definitely say following
those uh those videos online and
building them
and just uh seeing how they work
internally will give you like a lot of
experience
definitely way more than prepare for uh
like learning algorithms and stuff like
that
yeah yeah well i mean it's kind of one
of those things it's a it's a little bit
of a
you got to do both unfortunately right
but
um but i think to your point that's
almost a skill that we forget
is that a lot of what we're doing is not
inventing new code a lot of what we're
doing is i'm going to inherit your code
and i have to look at it and understand
it and then make it do something
mostly the same but a little bit
different or i have to patch one small
bug
i don't get to start from scratch and
that
interpretation that ability to
comprehend somebody else's code
that's probably the most valuable skill
you can have as someone who's new
yes definitely so like you said you do
have to learn both which is unfortunate
but uh what in terms of actually being
on the job and doing work
uh yes learning how to inherit code i
guess is a good way to say it
and learn how to work into your code and
oh i own this file let me figure out how
can i make it
more efficient um how do i extend it how
do i test it locally and
uh how do i review it because you're
gonna have to review other people's code
there's probably a close proximity to it
so like i would definitely say that
gives you like a lot of experience so
you're going to be building a portfolio
you're going to be learning how
different technologies work and you're
also if you follow the video step by
step you're going to be able to look at
someone else's code and figure out how
it works
um which is always not as
straightforward as you would like it to
be
so getting a lot of experience early on
would just
help you just go like a lot further once
you get into your job
yeah for sure so uh so one last question
before we wrap up uh
for all the folks out there who are
trying to get
their first opportunity and trying to
get their foot in the door um
you've already talked about you know
your your networking your ability to
visit the twitter campus
what what do you recommend for folks who
maybe don't have the opportunity to go
to a company's headquarters or to meet
people in person especially now that
we're in the pandemic
how would you recommend trying to get a
similar sort of networking going
remotely especially you know we've got a
lot of folks joining today from india or
from other places around the world
um how how do you think they can they
can get that similar sort of connection
without the ability to be physically
there
uh so i don't think uh it needs to be
physical like like i said some of the
first
like networking opportunities uh given
they weren't for
jobs but uh i feel like it still was
like a example of how
networking can open doors for you uh
we're on twitter so
like you don't really need the physical
aspect so i actually wrote an article
about
uh how i started on free code camp ended
up interning at twitter
all right this article i just talked
about from a to b
pretty much a lot of the stuff i've said
here and i think at the
at the end of the article i was just
like hey anyone has any questions email
me you know people email me
to ask questions i mean at this point
i'm like full of time on twitter so i
mean it's like i'm like hey
i could be your connection at twitter i
mean i'm not saying i could get you a
for sure job but
i could introduce you to people i can
help you study i can help you learn
yeah i'm gonna talk to about your
journey and i would say
maybe one or two people email me
um and then only one that i talked to to
this day
and she was just like really really like
adamant about it like hey
like you know like i have questions for
you man like i still keep in contact
with her to this day and she
uh i forgot the company she's got a job
at a company but she's like she's on it
like she's reading these articles
the people say hit them up she's hitting
them up uh because i mean like if you if
you're hitting people up
i mean if you get like a 10 10 rate i
mean you hit up 10 people a day
some one person is going to talk back to
you you know you don't know who that one
person is
so i definitely i mean if anything in
the past probably made it easier you
just sit in your room and
probably get connected with the world
well it's also removed that physical
advantage that other people might have
like i can't go drop into somebody's
office i have to email them too or send
them a dm or whatever
yes i mean it's a different like uh like
something that i never thought of
which one of my good friends helped me
realize is that
a lot of the social media platforms
they're helpful for getting in contact
with people
absolutely like instagram i never
haven't had instagram i
didn't have it for like maybe like five
or six years and then
one of my friends he was just like you
gotta get on instagram you know like a
lot of
tech people and vcs on twitter i mean on
instagram it's like you could talk to
them and it's just like you know they're
there and they're like you know like you
can go and interact with them and talk
to them and
they're very influential people yeah
like
i mean you could go on twitter uh
instagram facebook
probably not linkedin because it's just
too expected
there are a lot of ways to just find
people and then
they have like the virtual conferences
now but uh but
i would say the main thing is i mean you
just can't be scared like just
just throw throw up the emails i mean
i'm not saying throw up like a canned
email because
you don't like that but if you're
reading
uh you see like interviews and like i'm
like hey you know just reach out i mean
it doesn't take that long to respond to
the email
um so yeah so yeah like the person i
mentioned like
uh i forgot i would have to see how many
reasons i got on that it was a lot it
was
i believe it was five figures so tens
ten thousand no more
people that's not a lot of emails off of
yeah so
i mean that but that's a good that's a
thing like if you're out there thinking
that
if you take a shot you're gonna be one
of hundreds of of people in this
person's inbox
chances are that's not the case because
everybody thinks that everybody thinks
that everybody's sending
and nobody is like i don't get a lot of
emails you're not getting a lot of
emails like
i don't think that that people are as
flooded as you think so i think if you
if you reach out and you're in you're
genuinely asking not don't spam me for
connections
but like ask what are you working on
what are you stuck on what are you
excited about like
we want to hear from you that's fun for
us that's what we do with our friends
right
we're at time so um let me let me do
this let me
where should people go if they want to
if they want to keep in touch with you
is there a platform you prefer twitter
of course
what's your what's your twitter handle
it is two tips amazing
um can i i don't know if i can type it
in here but
um i'll type it
i have to have to recommend that flap
there it is okay yeah i spelled it right
but yes
so now i guess we're going to hey look i
guess after saying that i mean if i get
a photo uh dm's i can't do that
all right let me let me get this dropped
into the uh into the
into the youtube chat there you are
all right so uh definitely go give
jordan a follow
um you know take a look for that that
free code camp article quincy if you are
in the chat if you can
you can drop that um and then yeah
otherwise like
thank you so much for being here today
um if
if you all want to see more of these
we've got more connecting the dots on
the free code camp youtube
there's a series of them they're in a
playlist you can you can just search for
uh connect the dots on there
um jordan thank you again for taking the
time to hang out with us today any any
parting words for everyone
uh any part in words oh yeah so my
phrase that i pointed is protect your
dreams
uh you're gonna meet some lumberjacks
out there that don't try to take you out
say you can't do it uh say whatever
they're gonna say but
you just have to stay focused and just
get to the goal
so those will be my partners i love it
steer clear those lumberjacks i am
i'm so on board with that
made with that or something it's good
man it's real good
uh if you want to learn more with me i
run a weekly
live stream on twitch at uh
learnwithjason.dev or twitch.tv
uh jay langsdorf and you can come hang
out with me we learned something i
i pair with people uh we try to learn
something new in 90 minutes couple times
a week it's a lot of fun
this has been a lot of fun man this has
been so much fun thank you so much for
hanging out jordan thank you to the free
code camp team thank you
chad for for hanging out with us and
we'll see you all next time
see ya